[Music]
foreign
CDC reports one in three Americans are
in a sleep deficit yesterday the Sleep
Foundation reported 70 percent of adults
with poor sleep also reported depressive
symptoms that's according to a poll they
conducted on sleep and mental health so
the big question here is what can you do
to get a better night's rest we asked
Joseph dorjevsky the vice president of
research and scientific Affairs at the
national sleep Foundation
the national sleep Foundation is
committed to helping anyone and everyone
be their best left self we recommend six
small steps that everyone can engage in
that can make a big difference during
the day three small steps include things
like getting exposure to Bright Light in
the morning
increasing our levels of exercise and
having consistent meal times throughout
the days
at night we want everyone to avoid the
nicotine alcohol caffeine and heavy
meals immediately before bed we want
people to enjoy a nice relaxing wind
down routine something that involves
putting away those pesky electronic
devices about an hour before bed but
also prioritizes sleep make room and
make time for seven to nine hours per
night and finally where you sleep also
matters
we want your bedrooms to be cool quiet
and dark
to do it now we've got tips all week
long keep it right here good day great
sleep we're trying to help you out you
know what and we're selfishly trying to
help ourselves out too sure because we
know these are all the help we can get
it's tough I know some people I you know
it fascinates me some people sleep
upright in recliners and maybe if you
have breathing problems that helps you
know some people go to sleep with the TV
on and experts say absolutely not go but
other people say I can't fall asleep
unless I have noise and you know there's
something going on maybe everyone's a
little different everyone's unique yeah
the one thing I do which I'll tell you
and we go to bed early so that's that's
fair but I make sure that my cell phone
goes on silent you know it just
automatically does it every night about
4 30 that way I have time to wind down
did you notice that Heather said every
night at 4 30 that's still afternoon for
most people hey when you go to bed at
six pm everybody's going every night at
4 30.